do you think it's right that something
looked down measures are being eased
from touring well I think it depends
what your objective is if your objective
is to say that the virus needs to spread
through the population and you just need
to stay within health service capacity
then yes it makes sense to open up right
now when there's excess NHS capacity and
you have the ability to treat everyone
who needs it if your objective is to
contain the virus to drive numbers down
and to try to in a sense get rid of it
so no one is exposed to it then it is
not the right measure right now to open
up I mean there are currently 8,000 new
infections in England according to the
Office of National Statistics what level
do you think that should be at before we
start to ease the lockdown well if we
look at other countries which have been
opening out in which we want to be in
the position now I'm thinking you know
South Korea Australia New Zealand Norway
Denmark Germany they've been able to
bring down infections at least to the
low hundreds ideally into the double
digits to be standing at 8,000
infections a day to think a testing and
tracing system can do the work what you
really need is a package of
interventions and we're really far off
on that and we don't really have good
enough data systems to be able to
monitor at the local level so it's a big
risk and gamble we're exiting lockdown
with a larger number of deaths than we
did when we actually entered off
lockdown months back
members of Sage the Scientific Committee
advising the government have I spoken
out as to say that some of them believe
that the lockdown is being eased too
early at the government's own covert
alert system hasn't actually reduced
from a level four to a level three
do you think the government can really
still say it's listening to the science
no it's clear that there is a divide now
and these are political decisions and
science can advise on then so take the
issue of schools scientists can lay out
the uncertainty we can lay out the worry
about teachers and parents and
grandparents and wider community
transmission but the ultimate decision
has to be made by politicians so I think
what they should be saying is they
consider the science and hopefully they
listen to it with the decision and who
actually has the accountability are the
politicians and leaders do you think
it's inevitable that we could see a
increase in cases of coronavirus I'm
very sorry to say that I think it is
right now inevitable looking at the
numbers the only thing that might
some say save England is the good
weather and in the warmth if this virus
does indeed die outside quite quickly
but yes it's incredibly worrying because
the numbers are not low enough to have a
testing a tracing system take over the
countries that managed to exit what they
we want to be getting to is where
community transmission is eliminated
that you have clusters of cases
appearing and that these are like little
fires that you keep extinguishing as
needed through having a testing and
tracing system that can quickly monitor
and catch those so coming back to the
question of schools what we want to be
having is actually testing in schools we
need to be teaching treating schools
like how we've been treating hospitals
and care homes these are institutions
that need to be monitored and teachers
need to be tested older students need to
be tested we don't have yet those you
know monitoring systems in place and I'm
interested to get your thoughts or
something else as well because sage has
a suite released some minutes from its
and meetings in february/march I can see
from your Twitter over the last few days
that you've been pouring through them
and it's pretty clear with hindsight
that some of that early advice was
frankly off the mark and I do you think
this suggests that the government got
its early response to covert 19 wrong
and does this really underline that
sometimes a scientist can get it wrong
too yeah I think this what underlies
this is actually that you don't want a
small black box making decisions that's
not open to scrutiny science is all
about peer review scrutiny being
challenged having to defend your
position and show your data and evidence
and the UK was not doing this a group of
scientists and myself wrote a letter
actually right after that March 12th
fatal decision to stop tracing and
testing asking to see the evidence in
the data because we could not understand
it and it was not in line with what
scientists across the world we're doing
some of that advice looks at stopping
testing stopping tracing seeing this
virus is unstoppable like the flu to be
fair to the scientists they did change
their opinion by early March and we're
advocating by early March for a lockdown
and it took the government a few weeks
then to actually act on that advice but
yes I think the lesson from this is
transparency diversity at the table as
well as you know the mistakes that can
happen when you have a small group
making decisions for a large number of
people